three-time champion in the National
Basketball Association and also spent
some time in the front office of the
Chicago Bulls where he won those
championships at Detroit Michigan Durr
and now with the Wasserman group the
massaman Media Group the EVP and
managing executive and an agent to many
stars in the NBA good to see you again
BJ Armstrong how are you always great to
be back and it's great to be here so
good to see you really appreciate you
saying that what what do you think of
what the Warriors did last night what do
you take away from Game two that gives
you maybe hope or concern if you're the
Raptors what what do you take away from
o after Game one I was really concerned
to see what adjustments you know the
Warriors are gonna do in Game two and
Game two
you know I didn't see much room that
they could really do as far as making
adjustments you know the the Raptors
looked more active they look younger
more athletic and they really were
pushing the pace of the game but give
the Warriors credit for what they were
able to do they have the heart of a
champion they are a very persistent
group and more importantly they're very
mentally tough and they took away the
transition of the Raptors in Game two
they took away the ability for them to
get out there and get easy uncontested
shots and more importantly you know they
just really dictated the tempo of the
game and you got to give the Warriors
credit they found a way they have every
excuse with injuries and all of the
obstacles they're facing to really kind
of just give an excuse to not to play
and not to win but they find a way coach
Kerr and his staff as they found a way
last night even when they didn't look
good they found a way they were down ten
or twelve points I think in the second
quarter they found a way to get back in
the game the number of times as I said
to start this show that the third
quarter has been the Warriors quarter
and the number of times that we've
counted them out because of the injury
front that they keep on doing what
they're doing what is Steve Kerr doing
what I mean you've known as a player you
know the fill philosophy you also
represent JaVale McGee so you've got
player and dream you use represent dream
on you know you know how players are
placed into certain situations by Kerr
what does he
can you give us a better idea so does a
couple things that I think are very
interesting one he asked all the players
to provide the effort and energy
necessary to win the game and if you saw
last night
the Warriors brought the game they
brought the fight to the game last night
in the second quarter to me which was
the most critical moment or one of the
most critical moments of the game they
were down 12 points Steve Kerr allows
his team to figure it out on the fly
Steve never coaches his game plan he
coaches the game they were down 12
points and instead of the Raptors going
up maybe 15 or 20 to end the second
quarter the Warriors hung around yeah
and found a way to only be down 5 going
into the second half now so the I don't
you know to too many of us or I think to
the basketball fans maybe that wasn't a
big deal but last night that was to me
one of the most critical moments because
that was an opportunity for the Raptors
to really to take complete control of
the game they didn't do it
the Warriors hung around they felt good
about what they were able to do in the
second half and then Steve Kerr as he
always does he came out in the second
half and he designed a play every time
down in the second half for them to get
a shot not only a shot for a player a
shot for his main player which was Steph
Curry and klay Thompson and it allowed
the other players to kind of figure out
what to do in the course of the game and
they ran off like like 18 points or
something 18 no run in the third quarter
well I mean I showed my kids my two
oldest sons the movie Hoosiers for the
first time okay
you understand why I bring this up and
to say it was great you know sometimes
they you know how to explain to him that
you know Dennis Hopper wasn't really
drunk or anything like that but it was
the reason why I bring it up was coach
Dale played by Gene Hackman
four passes before even taking a shot
right and that's his philosophy and he
was trying to drill that into the guys
last night all xxii made field goals for
the Warriors in the second half came off
an assist every last one of them not a
single hero ball nothing and and how
does something like that happen I mean I
got is that occur philosophy that we're
seeing in play here
well you saw I think the big thing that
you saw in the first game was the
Raptors ability to get out in transition
right they saw two things really that
the Warriors did that the Raptors did in
first game they were able to get on
transition to allow them to score and
then you know that also the Raptors were
able to create turnovers and I was
interested in Game two what was Steve
Kerr and his staff going to do well the
first thing they did was they got to the
free-throw line they they cut down on
their turnovers okay and they were
trying to offensive rebound by playing
over the top they played big last night
and you saw Bogut you saw draymond green
get lobs you saw them do things to
really cut down on the transition of the
Raptors and they were able to play five
against five basketball which cut down
all the easy uncontested shots of the
Raptors and give the Warriors credit
they came out with the idea we're gonna
take this fight to the rafters and then
they were also going to cut down on air
their transition cut down on their
ability the Raptors ability to get out
just get uncontested shots in the the
Warriors did a great job Lance and
Cousins was just distributing he was
amazing they got like I think draymond
had like nine assists
I think boogie had like six assists you
got 15 assists or so from your bigs okay
and that's what they're saying what
they're saying is that you know exactly
right by the way you got those numbers
just off the top and then think about it
they have the ability to not only throw
the ball and operate from the low post
which you don't see often anymore they
were passers they were passes from the
post which you didn't see often so if
you were watching the game I'm sure like
the rest of us how were the warriors
able to get all these backdoor cuts is
because not only they occupied on the
strong side
they were running very creative things
on the weak side and one of the most
creative things I've seen in a long time
which Steve give him credit he was
allowing his scores his predominate
scores to become screeners they were
screening on the weak side and as we all
know as players the bet the player that
gets opened the most is the guy who sets
the screen and now you saw another part
of you know Steph Curry's game that you
hadn't seen he is a terrific screener
that's how he was getting open and
getting himself not only getting himself
open but he's getting his teammates open
but that was before Klay went out I
guess and BJ Armstrong here on the Rich
Eisen show let's
get to the box in 100 acres put into
play when klay Thompson went out the box
and one do we have Steph Curry's
response to that box in one defense the
whole fourth quarter they're playing
some janky defense just trying to send
bodies to me everywhere our whole roster
just took advantage of it right over the
course of the game that's God
disrespectful to leave envelope in like
that you know with the game online he's
made big shots like that before so let's
get the definition of janky for those
who may not know do you ever do you have
the definition of janky over there Chris
could you look that up for me please
yeah because that because today a lot of
people are hanging their hats on Curry's
response to all that about
Nick nurses defensive play you got that
over there Chris Genki means of
extremely poor or unreliable quality
would you agree with that I would not
agree with that um I was a party coach
nurse for having the courage to do a
boxing one at that stage of Game two of
the NBA Finals you know I've seen a lot
over my years but I was applauding you
know my wife was looking if she's like
what are you saying I was at home
standing up a party last night
that he had the courage to do this and
let alone during the season but in the
NBA Finals and the most astounding thing
to me is I didn't I think that has to be
the first time that the Warriors have
seen that and I think it was obvious by
the way they were running their offense
I don't think they knew what to do you
know I was looking to see what the
Warriors were gonna do to make some type
of adjustment but it seemed to be very
effective and I give coach nurse credit
of saying in the halfcourt we know we
can defend this team but you know
obviously they got to go out there and
win the game and execute can make shots
but for them to do that I thought it was
great and it was one of the great things
I've seen in the NBA Finals and I give
him all the credit and it's okay I still
want to applause I was so I was
impressed very impressed by that no it
certainly worked I mean this game came
down to a couple of possessions towards
the end and and if there's no clay and
no Durant
much easier to come up with more janky
things potentially for Game three do you
think Durant
needs to play for the Warriors to win
three out of the next five the Warriors
are gonna need to have a third score
okay they had great contributions from
their bench last night and make no doubt
about it Bucky was a huge asset for them
and he gave them probably more minutes
they didn't really know what he was
capable of giving and give him credit I
think he played like twenty-eight
minutes or so he did and he was really
terrific and I and I'm really happy for
him and their bench played well and
obviously Iguodala came a big once again
but he we always expect him to come up
big in big moments so but they got key
contributions from all areas from there
her entire team I mean they really
played a great team game last night and
then allowed them to come up with a
victory so oh yes or no answer yes that
was very agent engaging Armstrong do you
think Durant needs to play because you
can maybe get I do okay I think he needs
to play not so much fun before the
offensive end they can score enough
points I mean they've scored over what
108 109 points in two games in a row and
arguably they did that without a klay
Thompson in the fourth quarter so they
can score points
I think they need Kevin Durant more so
for the defensive end no Kevin because
they need extra bodies to throw at
siakam extra bodies to throw at a Kawhi
Leonard because you know they're there
down there down they could be down to
you know another two players with Kevin
Looney could possibly miss the game and
you're talking about a klay Thompson can
miss the game so defensively they're
going to need active bodies long bodies
athletic bodies who can match up and
give them the size that they need to go
out there and play the game to win the
next three games what do you think Nick
nurses BJ Armstrong here on the Rich
Eisen show what do you think Nick nurses
idea is gonna be over the next two days
what's his adjustment gonna be do you
think between games two and three based
on you saw last night well the thing
he's got to do is he his team came out
and they played hard they are very
physical team but they have to play
defense without following first because
you know they're gonna have the home
crowd they're gonna be playing on the
road
and they have to play with Saint
physicality but they're gonna have to
play without following so that allows
them to do what they do best which is
they use their athletic ability and get
out in transition and they're gonna have
to cut down on their turnovers okay Nick
nurse and that staff have proven that
defensively they are a defensive team
first and that's the great thing about
watching both of these teams and
watching both of these coaches is that
they're coaching defense first second
and then offensively they'll figure it
out as long as they can get stops on the
other end so they're gonna have that so
again I think the the Raptors are gonna
have to play great defense and then cut
down on their transitions and really
dictate the tempo on the role because
it's a much different animal when you're
playing and try to get a win when you're
trying to get a win on the road that's
compared to trying to get it at home did
you were you guys ever banged up like
it's physically banged up as the
Warriors are right now and like say
towards the end of your three-peat
towards the end of year three in a row
members banged up where guys are missing
games where we banged up yes yeah at
this time at this stage of the season
everyone's banged up well certainly at
this stage of a three-peat too I mean
you've youth right you'd coming off of
all that extra games that fewer teams
were were putting on the odometer yeah I
don't know what the the numbers are but
I would imagine over the last five years
or so for the Warriors they've probably
played another season and a half no
doubt like LeBron - right I mean the
Bron for the Cavs that's why a lot of
people are hoping that his sabbatical
for this year that he seems to be on
right now he's getting his rest is
forced sabbatical but so yeah so you do
I'm just trying to figure out if this is
an outlier what we're seeing right here
you know this it takes a toll on the
body and you can see the injuries that
they have but somehow they continue to
move on and figure out how to win and
figure out how to play so you know give
the Warriors credit they're not given
any excuses not to win the games and
they're fine in a way even though it
looks like they're out but they get off
the ropes and regroup and move on don't
make a prediction here who wins the next
who wins three out of the next five you
had to take a choice right here I'm
going to say the Raptors
I love the Warriors I love the fact that
the Warriors are the champ
and you never can count the champion out
but just looking at the activity I think
the activity and the youth will probably
went out if you can get to game 5 6 & 7
at some point you know missing being
down all the players that they are and
without them being healthy is going to
take its toll but again I think the
Raptors have to do it I thought that was
a great game for them to lose by big
numbers
meaning the Raptors but somehow someway
the Raptors throughout all of this and
they didn't play well last night they
had a chance to win this game even
though they didn't play well so I think
their youth will probably went out there
and you know as this is the series goes
on but it's it's gonna be a tough match
and I don't think the Warriors are gonna
lay down by no stretch of the
imagination I want to take a break and
come back with one more segment if I may
when I want to hit on your I stay in an
analyst type role but if you're with
your agent hat on okay-y first around
the corner and you having a client that
may or may not resign down the road
right here in Los Angeles and you having
had negotiations with the magic rob
Polanco a front office and so much more
if we don't mind Thanks right there okay
thank you that's BJ Armstrong right here
on the Rich Eisen show we're gonna have
a very interesting chat when we come
back here on this program
BJ Armstrong back for another segment
right here so in our segment just for
the television audience I asked how the
kid from Detroit wound up at Iowa and
not from Michigan and then you have the
floor now yeah so I wanted to go to
Michigan State being from Michigan
Detroit I was a huge urban Johnson van
Magic Johnson fan like everyone else
right so I go on my visit to Michigan
State and everything is going great I
judge the coach the coach Keith coach
the coach everything is great Ouisa was
there
Israel was there and it was everything
was going well and they had this young
guard he just got from Indiana Scott
Skiles and it was alright it was cool he
wasn't talking to me the whole trip but
that's fine that was Skiles scouts
wasn't talking to me but it was okay
and judge was like hey you know what
he's he's a competitor that's just how
he is but things would work out great he
was gonna be a freshman he was like you
guys could play for the next two or
three years together in the backcourt
it'd be terrific
at the end of that my visit like on
Sunday I leave and then Scott just out
of nowhere he just comes up to me he
goes good luck and are you / he said if
you do come here just be prepared to
cinema bench and play-by-play behind me
for the next three years this is what he
says - somebody says to me to your face
to my face all the coaches are there
like all other players are there so it's
like one of those awkward moments in my
life right I'm like 18 I'm all excited
and it was just like Richie was like it
was like one of those ways so the
coaches didn't know what to say you know
coaches and I we still kind of you know
laugh about it today it was like one of
those moms I was ready to come I was
ready to sign there and then I was like
I can't go here but didn't heathcote or
Israel call you up she said oh don't
listen we're the coaches we dictate this
sort of thing what it was already done
it was already back together and so
that's when raveling stepped in for you
traveling came in and you know Michigan
they were loaded you know they had the
judge memory and of course Barry R and
Cary Grant Roy Tarpley oh yeah Richard
relford you know and some of my friends
end up going there Glen Rice and Mark
Hughes and all those guys Louie Vault
all those just named the 89 championship
team three sets of it right myself along
with the late Roy marble we ended up
going to Iowa so it was good it all
worked out for the best but that was my
Scott Skiles story and so Scott and I
you know we're friends now we laugh
about it but it was one of the funniest
things ever he just came up to me that's
the only thing he said to me just be
prepared to sit on you know plate behind
me for the next three years or if you do
come here Chris when I was at Michigan
from 86 to 90 big Tim was loaded Oh
I mean we're doing talking about
Illinois yeah okay which is the team
that you know the the Steve Fisher
coached Glen Rice national championship
team how to get past Kendall Gill I mean
they were loaded Illinois was loaded for
the low do for high state Indiana India
I mean I remember when Indiana and
Alford came in and with Bob Knight into
Chrysler marina we would just give them
the business and it didn't go well it
didn't go very well for Michigan it did
not go well from that night those are a
good day Tim was loaded victim was mr.
it was a great conference and it still
is is great of course of course
but those were those were good days and
what's always fun running into the guys
BJ Armstrong here on the Rich Eisen show
okay so the EVP and managing executive
for the Wasserman media go sounds good
okay this is what I have written down
here sir okay so you represent JaVale
McGee yes who played for the Lakers this
year were you aware of all the the drama
that was going on in the building at the
time as the agent for JaVale McGee well
you know EJ you know rich the the one
thing about the NBA is there's always
something going on with every team you
know winning just covers it up you know
every team has the same issues except
when you win it just kind of goes away
was I aware of all of the things that
were going on yeah I was I was aware but
it was nothing out of the ordinary in
the sense that you know what this is
part of what goes on but you're an agent
and can you like call say Phil and say
Phil are you aware of what's going on
I'm sure you are you know because I mean
you have you have some aspects of your
agent at your disposal to try and well I
think as an agent now I have a kind of a
unique perspective because not only did
I play you know I was a an executive so
I worked in the front office I was part
of trying to help build these cultures
that you know you hear all of these
executives talking about now and in
working with ownership so you know the
one thing about you know the Lakers that
I think makes them unique is that you
have to manage the expectations of your
audience everyone was expecting the
Lakers to at the very least make the
playoffs and that is the one variable
that we really can't you know we don't
really know what the effects are because
if they would have made the playoffs
would this really be a story you know so
once they did make the playoffs and you
saw
the Lakers going in the opposite
direction is when everything started to
come out so you know and I remember text
winners used to always say you know
winning covers a multitude of sins it
just covers everything up and once they
didn't win and when they weren't going
in the right direction
you just saw everything kind of come out
and we're still talking about it today
well I mean there's a lot to talk about
I mean the ESPN article alone that came
out just recently I want to join a
couple items rich Paul riding on on the
Charter is that normal for an agent to
ride on a charter well it's not normal
but certainly there are agents now who
ride this is a new MBA and at one point
we would never allow me I flew
commercial when I first came into lead
right so a charter was just like that
was we were just happy to get on the
plane like Michael Jordan at a middle
seat is what you're saying
[Laughter]
okay but in today's NBA right it's not
uncommon do you ride charters I don't I
I I'm I'm I separate myself from the
players and the the business because I
can't be friends in the sense with an
executive and all of a sudden be expect
to negotiate right you know and there's
nothing I want to make sure that I
separate the business between my
friendship and the business of what
needs to be done there so I don't but do
agents now get on planes and charters
yeah you know family members it's a it's
a new MBA and it's a different time so
it's not uncommon
I don't know how common it is but I've
definitely heard of agents and family
members getting on charter planes today
so when you negotiated for JaVale McGee
with magic and Rob did you notice
anything was wrong in the front office
between the two it didn't but it was you
know there I think this magic synonym
second year you know the the one thing
about what the Lakers is I'm friends
with all of those all of those people
you know my grew up in Michigan I've
been knowing urban for 30-something
years I know Rob pálinka I know Jeanie
buzz so so what's going on there and I
don't know this is potentially a dicey
subject because you've got clients and
you want to negotiate there but can you
give me a sense of what yeah I can you
know
when I came in when I when I finished
playing in 2000 you know I hope he
doesn't mind me mentioning his name
Jerry Reinsdorf was a considerable boss
he gave me the greatest piece of advice
he said you know knowing what not to do
is more important than knowing what to
do and as an owner that is very very
very important for you as an owner of
knowing what not to do how to manage
people knowing what trades not to make
it's not just raised to make is to trace
what not to make and I think right now
that's what you're seeing with the
Lakers you're seeing Jeannie bus
learning what not to do and because of
this experience she will be better and
every owner who comes into this league
because they're so successful in other
businesses or other parts of their life
this is a different beast altogether
because you're managing people you're
managing expectations and winning
basketball games is different than going
out and selling or buying or making
money or whatever it is you did to
become successful in the first place and
this is a different animal so in my
humble opinion every owner who comes
into this league they go through this
this is part of their growing pains and
I think Jeannie bus is going through it
but I guarantee you this she will be
better
the Lakers organization will be better
but as a fan of the game and watching
this you're always like you're cringing
because you're saying this can be
avoided but it just takes time to get to
the next phase which she will learn and
what she'll get through I've got about a
minute left so just a quick lightning
round if you will yeah
the Anthony Davis trade did that mess up
the locker room that's that's very tough
because you never want to line up with a
guy that you're sitting next to saying
I'm trying to find your replacement
that's very tough just on a human level
forget whether or not he's a everyone
knows that Anthony Davis is a great
player and a great talent but you have
to treat your teammates in particular
with the respect because everyone is
going out there doing their very best
and many times if you are the star
player you have to come to the
realization that you know those players
who are the star players who aren't
getting the players call from them who
are getting the touches that they're
sacrificing to make you the star player
and that's very tough when you have
mm-hmm a player trying to get traded
during the course of this I've got 30
seconds left to JaVale want back in on
this without question he does JaVale had
a terrific year this year with the LA
Lakers I mean he arguably had one of his
best year some he put up one game this
year where he had like 30 and 20 so he
wants back him
absolutely I mean for sure BJ thanks for
coming on man thank you it's all that I
love having you on at BJ Armstrong on
Twitter for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
for free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app